[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good chef I paid them under the gun as
the clock was winding down and we're
looking inside the potato to pose Birds
steps back pump fake that is such a
precaution
Tatom to step away Church the Jews will
turn Nowitzki one leg fade away there's
the contact that's the space and bring
that foot down
maybe Lowry slaps the ball away or say
how that guy miss it well sometimes it's
not his responsibility you got to know
whether it's a drill official why or
something softer some start bigger this
game loves that step-back move they was
impressively about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
inside outside shot clock running down
no bottom will was dead this is the who
said 15 of us 30 here on the 4th
Corvette at 35 to go
[Applause]
Oh punch Tatum here and he gets in there
he's got two guys off and I'll watch a
little bit of a push there but look at
this fadeaway shot man that is tough one
on one and fall back baby after this
shake and bake with the Swiss alright
here we go
smart
[Music]
[Applause]
no question look at this shot I mean no
space to work
they came at three it wasn't - but look
at JC tail you waste no time at all
[Music]